reach sex is transactional in a society
that basically reduces sex to any sort
uh just a physical transaction that is
based only on consent it makes it very
difficult to explain why it is that the
casting couch in Hollywood is bad per se
right there's actually like a feminist
Theory says that it's bad because of
power imbalances he's sort of
libertarian culture of the left suggests
that power imbalance doesn't have
anything to do with it if I feel like
trading my body for a part in a movie
well that's my business and if you say
differently then you're shaming me
right so then bring back slut-shaming
bad bad well you can't really have it
both ways either it's bad or it's not
bad and if we are going to fight sexual
harassment and sexual assault it seems
to me that we have to do a couple of
things one we have to reinvest sex with
value Beyond just a physical transaction
it's not just two people who are getting
each other's rocks off okay Ben I'm
sorry I gotta do this every time I gotta
do this please bring these back